la nueva cepa del virus del hobbit 19 en
reinounido mantiene al mundo en alerta y
en el país crece la preocupación por un
aislamiento cada vez mayor que pueda
desabastecer lo comercialmente y ante la
mutación del virus desde la organización
mundial de la salud hicieron un llamado
a mantener la calma
el presidente electo de estados unidos
joe biden se aplicó la primera dosis de
la vacuna de facer variante contra el
hobbit 19 y lo hizo de manera pública
con el objetivo de transmitir confianza
sobre la inmunización el demócrata
recibió el fármaco precisamente el mismo
día que el país comenzó a administrar la
vacuna de la farmacéutica moderna
ya casi un año de las elecciones
generales de nicaragua el parlamento del
país estrecha el cerco a la oposición la
mayoría sandinista de la asamblea
nacional aprobó una ley que impide
llegar a cargos de elección popular a
quienes sean considerados traidores a la
patria tenemos reporte desde la ciudad
de managua
hola muy buenas noches bienvenidos a la
noticia de france 24 muchísimas gracias
por acompañarnos como todos los días soy
santiago díaz y comenzamos esta emisión
de noticias en reino unido donde crece
la preocupación y es que el país se
encuentra cada vez más aislado del mundo
por la propagación de una nueva cepa de
coronavirus que está poniendo en riesgo
también sus aprovisionamientos numerosos
países en europa y en todo el mundo
suspendieron sus vuelos con londres y
cerraron además a los británicos sus
fronteras
el bloqueo es especialmente dramático en
los accesos al euro túnel por el paso
del dólar con miles de camiones varados
francia fue uno de los primeros países
en cerrar sus conexiones con reino unido
y desde la pasada medianoche suspendido
durante 48 horas el tránsito de personas
con este país sin embargo ante la
mutación del virus desde la organización
mundial de la salud hicieron un llamado
a mantener la calma esto dijeron en los
últimos días hubo informes de una nueva
variante en sudáfrica y el reino unido-
united kingdom
y los virus mutan con el tiempo eso es
natural y esperado el reino unido
informó que esta nueva variante se
transmite más fácilmente pero hasta
ahora no hay evidencia de que sea más
propensa a causar una enfermedad grave o
la muerte y ante este escenario algunas
de las dudas y preguntas que
inevitablemente surgen ante esta
mutación del virus del coi 19 son por
ejemplo que tan peligrosa es esta nueva
cepa también cuán fácilmente puede
propagarse a lo largo de europa y si
podría dejar como obsoleta la actual
vacuna veamos más detalles en el
siguiente informe
la noticia hizo que los países europeos
se apresurarán para imponer
restricciones de viajes y reforzará sus
medidas sanitarias pero que tan probable
es que la nueva cepa del nuevo
coronavirus pase desde el reino unido
hasta europa continental a pesar de las
restricciones hay mucho contacto entre
el reino unido y el continente
especialmente en este momento del año en
el que la gente vuelve a casa para ser
honesto estaría muy sorprendido si la
cepa no estancia en francia y las
mutaciones son muy comunes entre los
virus y generalmente con pocas
consecuencias por ejemplo se cree que
luego corona virus ha mutado al menos
20.000 veces este año pero entre las más
de 20 mutaciones registradas de la
denominada cepa inglesa muchas impactan
directamente en la manera en la que se
transmite estas son mutaciones de la
proteína del pico que le permite a los
virus contagiar a los humanos e infectar
nuestras células las autoridades
británicas afirma que esto podría hacer
que la nueva variante fuera hasta un 70%
más transmisible pero eso no quiere
decir que sea más letal los científicos
también se han esforzado en destacar que
las mutaciones necesariamente no hacen
que los virus sean
resistentes a las vacunas por lo menos a
corto plazo
las vacunas están hechas para provocar
una respuesta inmune a gran escala así
que si hay una mutación en un punto la
vacuna lo controlará ya que incluso con
los virus que mutan extremadamente
rápido como el de la gripa usualmente
hacen falta entre cinco o siete años
para que desarrollen inmunidad a la
vacuna por ahora los científicos dicen
que no hay razón alguna para creer que
en el caso del cobi 19 no se tardaría
también el mismo período
vamos ahora a eeuu donde el presidente
electo del demócrata joe biden se aplicó
la primera dosis de la vacuna de facer y
bayonne tec al mismo tiempo comenzó la
campaña de vacunación con el fármaco de
moderna hablamos de la segunda
autorizada en el país y los trabajadores
de la salud fueron los primeros en
recibir la inyección los detalles los
tiene el informe de federico que
barberena
un gesto público para transmitir
confianza
el presidente electo joe biden recibió
la primera de las dos dosis de la vacuna
contra el hobbit 19 desarrollada por
facer y bayonne tec
el líder demócrata defendió la seguridad
de las inmunizaciones
estoy haciendo esto para demostrar que
la gente debería estar preparada para
recibir la vacuna cuando esté disponible
no hay nada de que preocuparse el
próximo mandatario estadounidense
reconoció la tarea del gobierno saliente
de donald trump para lograr el rápido
desarrollo de los fármacos y llamó a los
ciudadanos a mantenerse alerta esto va a
tomar tiempo espero que la gente escuche
a todos los expertos al doctor fauci
hablando sobre la necesidad de usar
mascarillas durante las fiestas de
navidad y año nuevo también mantener la
distancia social y si no tienes que
viajar no lo hagas
por otro lado comenzó la administración
de la vacuna de moderna la segunda
aprobada en el país en trabajadores de
la salud para ello es la medida alimenta
la esperanza quiero que la gente se
sienta tranquila recibiendo la vacuna
que está bien la vacuna es segura este
es un momento de esperanza para mí para
mis colegas y los pacientes que tratamos
estoy deseando volver con suerte a lo
que conocemos como normalidad según las
autoridades unos 3.700 centros de salud
recibirán cerca de 35 millones de dosis
de la vacuna de moderna entre lunes y
martes una distribución mucho más amplia
que la de facer debido a que el fármaco
de modernas se conserva con mayor
facilidad
avanzamos con noticias que llegan de
américa central y es que a poco menos de
un año de las elecciones generales en
nicaragua el gobernante frente
sandinista de liberación nacional
estrecha el cerco a sus opositores la
mayoría de sandinista que controla la
asamblea nacional del país aprobó este
mismo lunes la denominada ley de defensa
de los derechos del pueblo a la
independencia de la soberanía y
autodeterminación para la paz según la
cual no podrán optar a cargos de
elección popular aquellas personas que
sean consideradas como traidores a la
patria
más temprano ampliamos los detalles de
esta ley con nuestro corresponsal en
managua jorge hurtado esto nos decía
de esta ley cataloga como traidores de
la patria a toda persona que según el
criterio del gobierno proponga un golpe
de estado o actos de terrorismo o
inclusive alteren el orden
constitucional y es parte de una
retórica que ha venido utilizando el
gobierno de 2018 para referirse a
cualquier persona que no comulga con las
ideas que provienen del gobierno los
opositores ahora serán técnicamente
impedidos de participar en una elección
popular tras la aprobación de esta nueva
ley que contiene apenas dos párrafos y
que fue aprobada en tan solo horas por
la mayoría sandinista el presidente
daniel ortega se refirió a esta ley el
fin de semana durante un acto público y
fue un poco más claro dijo que lo que
pretende esta ley es que no se repitan
actos como los ocurridos a partir de
abril de 2018 cuando precisamente
iniciaron las protestas en contra de su
administración y el líder opositor de
rusia alexéi navalni asegura haber
engañado a un agente secreto de su país
para que revelara detalles del plan
fallido para asesinarlo con el agente
nervioso no visión naval y afirma que
uno
al presunto espía de los servicios de
seguridad de rusia y que éste le habría
confesado la autoría del ataque y desde
moscú nuestros corresponsales xavier
colás nos ampliar la información
ha sido uno de los espías que siguieron
a naval ni el que ha desvelado sin
querer como lo envenenaron colocaron
veneno no que en su ropa interior
lo ha explicado por teléfono el agente
konstantín cubrirse a efe al propio
naval ni que se estaba haciendo pasar
por uno de sus superiores
el agente comenta incluso que cree que
se puso más benigno de la cuenta pero
que algo salió mal en la misión tras
divulgarse esta llamada la policía ha
rodeado la casa del agente este es el
enésimo escándalo en torno al
envenenamiento de este líder opositor
ruso para engañar a la gente esta vez
naval y ha utilizado un sistema para
camuflar o disfrazar el número de
teléfono de tendencia la llamada y que
la gente pensase que la llamada provenía
del cuartel general de los servicios
secretos del fsb por cierto que el fsb
ha emitido después un comunicado
diciendo que la conversación es falsa
pero al mismo tiempo acusando ya a naval
ni de haberles engañado con ayuda de los
servicios secretos extranjeros las
respuestas de la gente registradas en la
grabación son la primera evidencia
directa de la participación de una
unidad del fsb en el envenenamiento de
naval ni
y vamos ahora a alemania porque este fan
valiente estamos hablando del autor del
ataque antisemita contra una sinagoga de
la ciudad de heart le ha ocurrido en
octubre del año pasado y que dejó a dos
personas muertas fue condenado este
lunes a cadena perpetua la sentencia
supone al menos 15 años de prisión para
variety y califica a este alemán de 28
años como un peligro para la sociedad
por lo que le retiraron la opción de
libertad condicionada durante la condena
la fiscalía consideró que ballet planeó
un ataque asesino contra ciudadanas y
ciudadanos de religión judía guiado por
su ideología antisemita racista y
xenófoba
de esta manera llegamos al final de otra
emisión informativa pero continúen
informando se en el resto de nuestra
programación y también en france24 punto
com
[Música]